the following game was played between
Garry Kasparov upon me Anatoly Karpov
who was white and Garry Kasparov it was
from their World Championship match in
Moscow in 1985 it was the 16th game of
that match i annotated the game in the
book winning chess brilliance ease and
every time I play through this game it's
just like this ah and you know our
inspiring game as I I want to say alien
chest
these guys play differently than me ok
in those days Anatoly Karpov was a
monster with the white pieces he
basically he basically played efore and
he said i win hey I'm white I got e4 I
win and he and he his philosophy was win
with Blatt win with white draw with
black and he was the dominant player
from the 1975 to 1985 in the world of
chess and his handling of the white
pieces with 1.e4 was terrifying
ok so that's the setup
Garry played his patented c5 the
Sicilian Knight f3 going for the open
Sicilian ISA 'kx d4 c5 takes d4 Knight
takes d4 so we have a the opening
developing pattern in front of us still
a lot of chess theory to go if anybody
has any questions by the way just raise
your hand and I'll be happy to call on
you and to explain any particular move
so Knight takes d4 the knight came out
to c6
and as we can see just from the opening
move for a moment there's a temporary I
think I can use that word temporary hole
is that that that squared D six is only
defended by the dark squared bishop and
Anna totally jumped on that by playing
the move Knight b5 so his idea is that
he wants to play Knight d6 check and
force the capture of the bishop and then
Queen takes d6 d7 d6 plugging up the
hole you can't attack there anymore so
White has moved his knight several times
and what what he aims to achieve is what
is called the mirach C bind
he played c2 c4 there was a Hungarian
player by the name of Giza orgasm arokh
C from Hungary who loved from Hungary
loved to set up his pawns on c4 and E
for and the whole idea of this set up
with these pawns was to control this
very very key square in the middle of
the board the d5 square okay c4 Knight
f6 attacking the pawn on e4 Knight
defends o xscape let me just try this
yeah I could change colors too by the
way I mean so like just to let you know
just so I'm not one I'm not only green
light you know I can do red yellow a
seven a six attacking the knight and
chasing it to the side of the board
Knight a three so what White's idea is
is he wants to play Bishop e2 Bishop e3
castles Queen D do bring his rooks into
the center and keep black cramped he
wants to keep black he would love to see
black play moves like Bishop e7 Bishop
d7 castles and black doesn't have much
space white plays behind his broad
center so that he could put his bishops
on e3 and e2
at that time the idea was that because
white has a cramping position against
his opponent when the night comes back
to d4 it gives black the opportunity to
trade pieces so white wants to avoid
trading the pieces for the moment and to
let black enjoy the cramped position he
has so if I have an advantage of space
and we're down into a King and pawn
endgame might not be meaningful but if
the board is full of pieces and I have a
big cramping influence in the center
your pieces won't have as much mobility
as mine yeah the cramp because these two
Center ponds control yet our more
advanced in control is work so we do it
another way as we did it in the first
class the pawn on e4 controls two black
squares pawn on e6 doesn't control any
of White's pawn on c4 controls two black
squares pawn on d6 doesn't control any
of whites so this position remarkably
enough has been reached thousands of
times over a century century and a half
maybe even longer and Gary came up with
an absolutely wild surprising move play
d5 it's like bang in your face what's up
with that White's whole strategy up to
now has been to stop this advance and
Gary just says I'm advancing this is for
me what chess is at the highest levels
is a battle of ideas that's really what
it comes down to right you have your
ideas I've got my ideas White's idea was
to stop this advanced black said you
haven't stopped the advance
white said yes I have okay anatoly
karpov plate C takes d5 e takes d5 eat X
d5 Knight B for now what black is saying
is I'm going to I'm going to win back
this pawn on d5 what you're going to do
about it
what do you think white should do about
it you man yeah yeah Bishop c4 that
looks like a really natural move you're
developing a bishop that hasn't yeah and
you're protecting the pawn what could be
more simple so Bishop c4 so let's
imagine that black plays b5 attacking
the bishop you want to keep that pawn
protected don't you so you would play
Bishop back to b3 then let's say black
played Bishop to e7 we would Castle
absolutely castles castles then we
understand what black wants to do blacks
next move his intention is to play
Bishop b7 and to attack the pawn on d5
yet again notice that one of the strange
things is that this knight on a3 is
really ineffective okay so what Karpov
did and I think Bishop c4 is a very good
move but Karpov made a little bit of a
deeper insight
Karpov said I bet I bet I know what my
opponent wants to do I bet my opponent
wants to play b5 and Bishop b7 that he's
going to do that so I'm going to put my
bishop on e to
sorry to the second new mainline bishop
on e - and I'm going to invite black to
recapture his pawn and one day my
bishops going to go to f3 if black tries
that b5 Bishop b7 business I'm going to
put my Bishop on that journey
okay so garry kasparov said you can keep
your pawn I'll play Bishop c5 again did
I say alien chess by Mesa yes exactly so
you know like I'm like you guys die man
I love pawns why on earth didn't a black
capture the pawn yeah exactly
so let's imagine that he it played night
on B takes d5 White's intention was to
Castle okay now let's say Bishop to e7
Knight takes F knight Knight takes d5
Knight takes d5 Bishop comes out here to
f3 now our Bishop on f3 is doing really
good stuff man it's like attacking the
knight it's on this diagonal so you
don't want to move that night you want
to defend it you play Bishop e6
outwardly to all appearances lacks
pretty okay like what's wrong with
blacks position until you see this move
Knight c2 now you start to think oh I
got it issues the knight is going to
come to d4 and then it's going to take
my bishop so I'm going to lose the two
bishops in an open open board but even
worse when the night comes to d4 and
takes the
it's going to mess up my Han structure
yeah f6 now okay so the move
f7 f6 so the idea your idea if I can
guess it is that when I move my knight
you want to be able to move retreat your
vision
okay so I'll centralize the knight
Knight to d4 attacking the bishop the
bishop will drop back one Square and
I'll play Knight f5 I'm attacking the
bishop on e7 but more importantly at the
moment I'm attacking this pawn on g7
maybe I also want to play rook e1 but
there's a real nice trick you want me to
show you a nice trick
imagine that you castle you know this
one what is it
yeah then I win the two bishops but even
nicer is this one Bishop takes d5 Bishop
takes d5 that's a juicy one isn't it
check and I've got the Royal fork after
Queen takes d5 I get the Royal Fork
so this was all looking very normal and
then the question was why he didn't take
the pawn well it's a deep answer and
sorry I had to go that deep but that's
what that was all about was that it
turns out that the night somehow ends up
being vulnerable on the d5 square
well Gary instead of recapturing played
the move Bishop c5 he simply developed
and white castled and black hassled and
white played Bishop f3 and now at the
time I didn't get it at all I thought
wait a minute isn't Anatolia well what
is Gary doing isn't anatoly karpov a
pawn ahead and a passed pawn ahead you
know and you know isn't black and bad
shape well I gotta tell you was I in for
a surprise
so as Anatoly Karpov and it's Oh Gary
just kept developing like hey no problem
I'll just bring my pieces out how are
you going to bring your pieces up with
the move Bishop f5 what makes that move
so particularly good got somebody yes
young man
yeah it controls the see 2 square so
this night can't come here
also if the night comes to see 4
sometimes you can pop into d3 attacking
the rook as well as the night so the
move Bishop f5 kind of freezes the night
on a3
keeping that night out of the game white
develops his piece black says hey the
rook I just bring the rook to the open
file just putting my pieces on very good
squares rook e8 Queen came to d2 and now
Gary played the movie 7 b5 like he's
just a pawn down but he's ignoring you
know like I'd be sweating cannon ball I
meant down upon how am I going to get it
back Gary ignores the pawn and he says
with this move B 7 B 5 I'm really
limiting this night the night can't come
here the knight can't count there the
only thing that Knight can do is move
backwards to original screw exactly so
hey you're a pawn up that's ok yeah I'm
up on up rook on a to d1 the rook comes
behind the pond maybe one day Black's
not watching this pawn might come up the
board supported by the Queen as well as
the rook rook a d1 Gary made a great
move Knight to d3 that night just comes
dead in the center white Center earlier
a class I had earlier tonight it's
talking about primary squares for her
Knights well that's our primary square
baby that night just comes right in the
center of the board and by the way
it also unleashes a potential threat of
b5 before attacking one of the Knights
forking the Knights okay
so white wants to step out of this
excuse me white wants to step out of
this threat of B 5 B 4 so he steps back
with his knight and with the idea that
he's going to unravel going forwards
okay
black puts the question to White's
Bishop h7 h6 do you want to take my
knight or don't you and Anatoli answers
a question no I don't Bishop h4 drops
back now
great whites upon up and what's the
problem I think that black is going to
have a hard time here eventually this
Bishop might just simply drop back to e2
and kick this night out of the way so
art isn't white just upon a head how
many of you would prefer to have white
hide raise my hand I like the extra pot
but Gary had seen very very deeply in
the position and he played the move B
for attacking White's night white played
Knight a four and Gary simply retreated
the bishop and Gary said I'm a pawn now
but your pieces are terrible the knight
on a 4 is out of the center the knight
on b1 has no it hasn't moved it it's
like on its original square yeah
exactly at the moment even though he's
upon ahead
so I Karpov seeing nothing better played
the move Bishop g3 and Gary said ok I'll
put my rook on this open file hold on a
second
yeah baby
so I got to our so it's sort of like all
of the good squares if you will belong
to Gary and all of the misplaced pieces
the night on a for the night on b1
belong to Anatoly even though all of his
new moves up to this moment look pretty
normal
yes right but this night on d3 is like
an octopus right it's reaching into all
of the key squares II 1 and C 1 you
can't bring your looks and the night
controls a lot of space so a really
strategic masterpiece that is happening
at the moment and Anatoly says ah well I
better free up the square b2 so that I
can drop back here with my night excuse
me I can drop back here with my night
get rid of your very very powerful night
on d3 and then I'm going to have fun and
it's my turn I'll have the extra pawn
and we'll see how you enjoy yourself ok
so we can see that white actually has
some kind of a strategic threat of sorts
and that threat is to play Knight b2 and
black has to react promptly what move do
you think Gary played
what did Gary do by the way just a
warning anybody who gets it right
comes up here and we trade places any
guesses any guesses it's sort of like
Black has kind of maximized well maybe
his Queen isn't maximized his rooks his
knights as bishops everything is playing
even the queen is actually okay on d8 so
with all of his pieces maximized and
Gary needing to create threats plate the
move g5o
g5 you know launching the pawns in front
of your king you know as a coach I would
like slap your hands and say what are
you doing and I'm making me look mad
every are you didn't you know your
parents who are watching g5 exposing
your King but creating a very very nasty
threat of g4 in the position why is this
threat nasty because when you play g4
you drive the bishop back the knight
jumps to e4 Queen captures the knight
Knight takes the bishop discovered an
attack against the Queen the knight and
the rook and the rook so white would
lose material in the face of g5 g for
Bishop takes d6 Queen takes d6 g3 in
order to make a retreat for the bishop
just kind of like what you are saying
that f6 move you says yes it so g3 to
make a retreat for the bishop so black
to play what did Gary play
and man
oh by just simply taking the pawn Knight
takes beef up that's probably a move
that I make taking the pawn and it looks
reasonable so maybe we would go for
example Knight takes pawn Knight back to
b2 and yeah yeah well here's the thing
it's a kind of a deeper thought I like
your move okay flatout
I like recapturing the pawn but in it in
it in a sense like after Knight takes d5
let's say Knight B to the Queen and the
rook on the D file the D file is open to
threats right so Gary actually played
the move Knight d7 and this was actually
a brilliant move the idea is that black
says that pawn on d5 messes you up it
means that your Bishop is passive it
means that the D file remains closed and
I'm going to play around the knight on
f6 is now so when the night comes back
to B - we can play Knight e5 and protect
the knight also this Knight wants to
come to e5 to attack the bishop this was
a very cool game Knight d7 okay so why
just step back with as Bishop Anatoly
sees that the knight wants to come to e5
and attack the bishop so he moves his
knight out of the way
in anticipation of the knight coming
also what Anatoly is thinking is that
maybe this will allow him an opportunity
in the future
to play move like f to f4 and to try to
take advantage of that launching of the
Jeep on what did garry kasparov do what
move did he make black to move black to
move
I'll give you a hint the hint that I'll
give you is that whites nights are out
of play but we know that Anatole wants
to bring this night on a for back into
play how can you stop him army night to
c5 but that will allow white to make a
trade of nights okay so how yes
bravo Bravo Queen f6 so the idea here
was just to stop just to escape just to
control this f6 square and basically say
to to white I'm not going to let you
trade your offside night for the good
night on d3 Queen f6 notice that this
night on b1 it's terrible
why is this night on b1 terrible because
this pawn um before it can't move so
Anatole played a3 to try to bust out
breaking out of prison what are you
going to do you're going to let black
what would let white you bet a5 a takes
b4 you're going to recapture with the
night no way you're going to recapture
with a pawn
so here Anatoly is he's a pawn up but
what on earth can he do for a move his
rooks can't move his Knights can't move
his Bishop has moved already and why we
going to move the bishop again we can
move the king but that's not anything
special
we've got anatoly's decides
he's got to move his queen out of the
way so that he can put his knight on b1
to the d2 square where can he move his
Queen working white move white wants to
move his knight to d2 only square Queen
a2 but you gotta admit that clean on a -
looks pretty pretty pathetic right like
Queen a - okay Queen a - bishop g6 this
is like one of those very quiet moves
that just basically says - white go
ahead make a move and with my bishop on
g6 I'm opening up the Queen so that
maybe I could jump with my knight and
jump with my knight here so that my
queen is improved the bishop was
blocking my view and by the way it's
your turn go ahead make a move now
Anatoly realizes gee if I move my knight
to eat d2 the rook will come down and
pin my knight well I don't want to
invite that rook into my camp
so anatoly's disgusted with his extra
pawn it take my punch just just get rid
of my pond will you please take my pump
so anatoly's idea is that after Queen
takes d6 92 rook e - you can go Knight
c4 and attack the unprotected Queen
yeah so Gary said Amen I don't like your
bomb I don't need your pond I will play
the move g5 g4 and what's the idea
behind this move and then
yeah and this pawn on g4 takes over some
control of the light squares yes so g4
okay well that idea of Knight d2 and
rookie to allowing rookie to simply
didn't work and it totally said okay
I'll bring my queen back Queen d2 please
take my pawn so that I could take the
pawn on h6 Gary says you can't have that
one no no I'll keep my pawn on gg7 and
keep my pawn white is running out of
things to do and he finally decides okay
he's got to bust out he plays the move
f2 f3
notice that this move exposes White's
King to some checks on a diagonal like
the Queen could come here to d4 with
check so white does exposes his is king
but on the other hand you got to do
something okay so because Baro says now
now is the time I want to capture the
pawn and white says okay great I'll
capture this pawn on g4 and black says
check to the King King to h1
Knight comes to f6 whoo now things
notice again the Queen on d4 is in a
dominant position it dominates this
night this night on b1 is dominant this
Knight on d3 is great but now black
wants to go Knight e4 so that he can
threaten a check on f2 and man white is
going to get busted Knight f6 great move
okay it's desperation time now for
Anatoly and Anatoly plays rook F for
attacking the Queen how many of you want
to take the rook good very good so what
did what did Gary do what move did Gary
make now after rook f4 he's going to
take your queen there you go
move it somewhere yes exactly
Knight to e4 anyway bang Knight to e4
anyway blocking the attack attacking the
Queen and threatening Knight F to check
right Queen captures d3
bad move night f2 check just a second
yes it was panic rook takes f2 Bishop
takes Queen rook on f2 d2 so now if it's
whites turn white wants to play Knight
b2 and take this bishop then you'll have
three minor pieces for his Queen and
white will be doing very fine so what on
earth could which move rook III so if
you go over let's see it if you go rook
III what is your intention after night
b2
rook d8 that but then it's sort of like
whose pieces are getting tied up I'm not
quite sure whose pieces are getting tied
up what Gary played was a really cool
move he went Queen III and he said I'm
getting out of the pin getting out of
the pen but can't white take the bishop
why not that's what he did
hey it's legal what move now are you
going to make are you going to make take
my rope what yes what take the rook so
your idea is that after I take the rook
I'll take your queen check I'll move my
bishop you'll take my bishop I'll move
my king you'll take and then you'll be
an exchange ahead maybe you win maybe
you won't maybe you won't so
Gary didn't take the rook yes a
beautiful route rook c1 now his idea is
if you take my queen I'll take your rook
I'll take that rook I'll take that
Bishop I'll take that night rook c1 and
with this move lick c1 he's also
threatening to take this Knight and
maybe also to take this rook and to take
this pawn on b3 so rook C one fantastic
dazzling move Knight b2
Knight b2 so now Gary is definitely
winning but did you guys ever notice one
thing about chess one of the most
difficult things in chess is to win a
winning position boy I'd say I'm sure
I'd have 300 more rating points
everybody won all the winning positions
that I let escape so here black has a
winning position and he's got to bring
home the bacon
how would you achieve that huh how do
you win a winning position
well my yeah my first thought would be
to take the rook and Queen take that
rook rook takes that rook that should be
winning you're right that should be
winning Gary came up with a even more
clever move what move did Gary Queen e1
Shack that looks like a devastating move
I think
Queen e1 check would run into Bishop f1
I'm not sure well then I take you know
ruck and we get in that same yeah right
so you could go rook takes d1 rook takes
d1 Queen e1 check I'd play here and
again I'm losing but well white is
losing here but I it's not as absolutely
cut and dry so here white black has a
really good move really really really
good move
so Queen e1 check rook takes d1 those
are winning moves but once you see
blacks next move you think that was yes
not be committing suicide about that
yeah that's suicidal rook takes b1 rook
takes III yeah suicide are we ready
Queenie close that's that's the best
Gary Fung Queen f2 BAM
woo with the threat of rook e1 and it's
going to be checkmate
also notice that with this move on top
of everything else there's clean tags B
to notice that night on b1 hasn't moved
in like forever right so Queen f2 Knight
d2 now how did Gary mop him up yes
rook takes rook Knight takes check and
resigns yeah knocked everything isn't
that an amazing game I mean just uh it
was both from a powerful strategic
mastery where White's piece has just
kind of got pushed aside and black just
took over all the key squares so when I
saw this game I was like wow I don't
play chess like that I mean that was
that was pretty good and that was one of
the reasons why Gary was one of those
amazing world champions ever this was an
awe-inspiring game